kourtney kardashian gets a unique
makeover
courtesy of her nine-year-old daughter
penelope i love it
the keeping up with the kardashians star
took to her insta story on thursday
sharing this snap of her little girl on
her ninth birthday
writing alongside it she's doing my
makeup
and the end result was a full-blown look
complete with rhinestones down the
bridge of her nose a bright pink lip
and faux face tattoos i mean it was
beautiful amazing the 42 year old pooch
founder shared the final product
and took a poll asking fans to weigh in
and you know what
they loved it thank you court posted a
ton of throwback pics of her little girl
to her story
and shared this snap to her feed along
with a few clips of her boyfriend
travis barker teaching her daughter how
to play the drums
she captioned the post quote my birthday
girl my favorite girl in the entire
world
i am so happy and proud to be your mommy
i cannot believe that you are nine
my life is so much better because of you
[Music]
and travis he shared this video of p
rocking out next to her famous mama on
his insta story
along with some birthday love
of course things between court and
travis have been heating up
with a source previously telling et
quote courtney and travis really
recognize now
more than ever how special their
relationship is
and how fortunate they are to spend
their time together whether it's just
the two of them
with friends or with their families of
course the reality star shares three
children with her ex scott disick
while travis has two kids from his
marriage to shayna mokler
and e.t source says they feel like their
biggest accomplishment so far
is how seamlessly they've integrated
their families
quote that's always been very much a
focus for both of them
and they feel proud that everyone can be
supportive of their happiness
but back to penelope's birthday her dad
scott disick
shared this sweet post on instagram
writing in part
quote my life my love my everything you
have changed my life
forever peep it's such a beautiful thing
penelope's aunt khloe kardashian shared
this cute selfie alongside the caption
just like that she's nine meanwhile the
matriarch of the kardashian jenner fam
kris jenner shared some pics of her own
calling p
her little cutie pie granddaughter you
are the brightest light the smartest
girl the most amazing chef an incredible
musician
the most creative at planning special
events and surprises
the most thoughtful granddaughter
amazing daughter sister cousin and niece
and make every single day i am with you
very special
you